One way that it's helpful to approach word problems is to start off by thinking
about what information we already have. In this problem, we know that the
number of ants is equal to 3 times 10 to the 3rd, and the length of one of
those ants is 2 times 10 to the negative 4 meters. Once we know what
information we have to work with, we can think about what we want to find. In
this case, that's the length of the entire line of ants. All these ants lined
up in one line. To get from this information to this information, we need to
multiple these two numbers together. So, we need to calculate 2 times 10 to the
negative 4th, times 3 times 10 to the 3rd. Now the way we would normally write
those numbers, would be 0.0002 and 3,000. So two 10,000ths times 3,000 is equal
to 0.6. So now we can conclude, that the whole line of ants is 0.6 meters long.